what up it's your boy mano the kob check
me out on bootleg calf podcast
bullet cab show special guest in here my
guy man yeah mano yeah welcome welcome
what's up brother i'm good man hey
you've been killing it lately bro i'm
i'm trying man i'm having a resurgence
man i love this podcast
love the podcast uh i love what you're
doing with jim thank you thank you and i
love the just the vibes of the the
getting fit what give me give me this
it's you fab and me fab
jim david pulling up yeah we all we all
you know
coming together working out
you know doing music
you know uh motivating
inspiring people man how many people
around the world want to work out want
to take care of themselves how many
people say around uh
you know new year's eve what did you
know everybody resolutions is gonna be i
seen it listen
today
just today
i stopped to see uh my guy steve labelle
shout out to my brother steve shout out
to steve lebo shout out to uh lemonade
and van nuys i went there
did you go to his rehab as well i didn't
go to the rehab but i went to lemonade
all right
and van nuys
and one of the dudes that worked there
said to me man you inspired me man to
work get me back in the gym wow i go in
the gym because i watch out
so the thing the thing about that is
like
i didn't i always worked out
on and off
all my life like i never
worked out
for more than like six seven months at a
time though right then i will always be
on and off you know you know two months
you know i'm going strong for two three
months and then i fall off but the thing
about when you got a group of people
that you work out with and y'all got
things in common
it motivates you so the fact that i
might get up in the morning and we got a
group chat that we all be in a group
chat
and and and when i see like fab in the
gym
it makes me want to get up and go to the
gym like all right [ __ ] it the homies is
in there because we'll be checking on
each other no matter what like so i'm in
la
you know
anybody could be anywhere i was going to
the gym while i've been here
okay and just because we all in that
group chat what's up what we doing get
that money no matter what no matter
where you at get it accountability man
yeah you got the homies yeah a couple
homies and you like the results you like
how you feel you like how your body
feels
after that so
it's cool that's dope motivating a lot
of people man yeah i think too like uh
like i just started training
and i feel like it
you know a lot of people like yeah
trainers expensive but i'm like i i feel
like i'm not paying him to train me i'm
paying him because if i'm paying him so
i feel like i have to go right it gives
you that money and i know and this dude
will be in my he'll be in my phone like
bro what the [ __ ] you need that push you
gonna do it on your own right and that's
the thing everybody and that's the thing
about
having a trainer
jim jones is like a trainer
yes for us like
like nah we we we're doing these today
like super sets he's he's an animal like
he wants to he wants he's been yoked for
a while yeah he's he's he's he's crazy
with it but the thing is
the average person might feel like they
need to get in the gym with a trainer
because that's the motivation that they
need that trainer is going to be on your
line early in the morning like yo get up
let's go get up
you need that push we all need that push
sometimes and we'll uh when you're
actually working out hold you over the
fire
right because you know when you're
working out alone you might you ain't
going as hard as you go if someone's
like no two more three three more hell
no you teach yourself a lot of [ __ ]
yourself a lot i know i do 100 i think
everybody does that's a fact oh i'm good
i'm good i thought i got it i did
something yeah i did something something
better than i broke a sweat yeah you
don't go home yeah exactly are you doing
anything on the diet like are you are
you trying to eat right as well i'm
running off with that though that's the
toughest part yeah yeah that is i just
did like a seven-day
um
liquid diet like i was just doing
protein
protein shakes and protein balls for
seven days i just did that that was it
yeah i wasn't touching nothing else but
the thing is it's like balance the
problem with that is that like i lost
like seven pounds
and then
you know you get right back into eating
the same stuff that you
wasn't you know that you ain't eating in
seven days
so you kind of put it back on but
excuse me i like to do a lot of cardio
i like to have my heart pumping i like
to
bust that sweat because i feel like
cardio is just important than anything
else yeah you know you never know we
might have to be wrestling some [ __ ]
every now and then you know what i mean
you never know this has happened this
happened this has happened of course
speaking of that
you are uh
in my opinion probably the most infamous
slapper in hip-hop
when i think of uh
just rappers getting slapped or checked
i just think of mano and obi in oh wait
are you i mean
hand to god
um
how would we rate the will smith slap
that was a nice slap
that wasn't but i looked at it close
i don't think his palm connected
it almost like he held back a bit i
don't know if he held back but what
happened was that
he went up so he went up high right and
chris rock rolled with it
so i think when he when he when he was
moving his face like that i i feel like
he missed the palm because i saw it in
slow motion
and i felt like his fingers
caught him
i don't know if he caught the whole um
like that right because if you i mean it
probably would have been because chris
took it like a champ but he like you
said i don't think he got because if you
get hit with that palm palm is the poem
that poem is different it's different
the palm is different when you catch him
with that with palmer and father his
daughters is different palmer and five
it's different all right
palmer father his daughters
is different
it's
so i don't know if he caught that i
think he caught just i looked at the uh
the slow motion of it
when you uh i mean obviously when i
first saw it i was like i because i saw
carter khan alive i was like
me too but then i but then the second
time he started screaming and you could
hear his voice cracking i'm like oh no
that's that's what i know it was real
yeah because he smacked him and then he
talked down to him
right so he smacked them walked away
the smack looked fake
right right because i'm looking at it on
instagram
when he got
when when the footage came out of of
what he said afterwards is when we
really knew it was real when he was like
keep
my wife's name out your mouth no we've
all heard people we've all screamed like
that at somebody yeah that's that's when
you tie it yeah that's when you tie it
that's when you fed up enough's enough
enough's enough that's when you fed up
with a lot of [ __ ] and just like man
like
i'm tired of you i'm tired of playing
with you [ __ ] keep my [ __ ] wife's
name out your [ __ ] mouth
period it's almost like chris rock just
wore
everybody's all the memes from the last
few years all the people making jokes
it's like chris chris walk he just held
the the
the blunt of all of that
i love chris rock chris rock actually
one of my favorites as far as comedians
is concerned he's like in my top two
actually yeah to me it's him and
chappelle stand up wise stand up i'm
someone strictly stand up he's like one
of my he's like one of my he's like he's
one of them right for me
so man
i don't know if it i don't know if it
was
a lot of stuff that
will's been dealing with because listen
let's keep it real man in like life
people got this thing about celebrities
where they feel like
celebrities aren't as human as other
people of course and
people dealing with [ __ ] man everyday
life [ __ ] ups downs
you know on your quest to chase after
your dreams and
on your quest to conquer
conquer other other other
goals
there's a lot that you dealing with man
family issues
um
you know uh expectation issues you know
of other people so it's a lot then you
got to deal with we living in a time
where
we didn't we didn't used to hear
the opinions of everyone of everybody
right
social media made everybody accessible
to is like
you can't turn the noise off
as soon as you open your phone there's
an opinion about you mm-hmm as soon as
you so and the phone has
the phone is is your
it's your everything
so to speak because this is where you
find your media this is where you find
your news this is where you find
everything you want to you want to see
what the weather is like you got to
check your phone check your phone most
people don't have watches anymore they
gotta not they got an apple watch
right nobody's even worried about
what the what the watch say right right
so
as soon as you open up your phone
there's an opinion about you there's a
statement there's a thought
there's a
there's a uh
a criticism
there's a joke there's whatever
and people
artists celebrities
or what have you on any level
have to deal with that
and it's like
i have to have a
thick face black heart mentality and not
allow certain things
to ruffle my feathers
but sometimes at some point
people become human and they're not in
the move to play
you understand so
i'm not one of them [ __ ] that that
feel like
oh
you shouldn't handle problems with
violence i don't believe in
that i believe that
there's a there's a time and a place
for everything
and i believe i mean
like in a country that was built on
violence don't preach to us now about
right
violence when this is the whole culture
of this country
in its inception and what went on here
for
thousands
hundreds of years right not thousands
hundreds of years
and
i don't i don't think like i'm not here
to like say oh he's wrong for
handling his business maybe he should
maybe shouldn't have been there or
whatever but when you're in your mode
you're in your mode and how you feel is
how you feel
as a man now as a man you feel
disrespected in however you want to deal
with that disrespect
is
solely
up to you period point blank
yeah i would say like you can't tell
people how to react to this right that's
the thing people got a problem with that
[ __ ] say uh
some some slick [ __ ] to you
and then you go crazy on them
and then he'll say
it ain't that serious
[ __ ] it's not that serious to you right
but it's
optimum serious to me
this is maximum serious to me
what you care about is different than
what i care about your lines your
principles your code is different than
mines so
don't tell me
it's not that serious and oh you had to
do all that [ __ ] right
so that's the thing that's the
difference and you know that's that's
people i mean you know they just you you
somebody would disrespect you and then
tell you you shouldn't have
handled them
you meet disrespect with what with
disrespect right i mean at least
i mean obviously like you said it i
guess it's a subjective thing depending
on
some people
can take [ __ ]
a certain way or or or be the bigger
person but at the same time right at the
same time and then here's the thing on
the flip side to that is
people say was the joke that's serious
i understood the joke now it's like okay
here's the thing
if jada is really having a what they say
she has a
condition condition with her yeah she's
not she's not losing her hair
because she wants to cut it off
she cuts it off because she what has to
or or whatever i would say you don't
make fun of people for things they can't
change right so that's something
you know that's a little bit more deeper
because that's a medical condition and
then you know you could tell like so
many people like like i just listened to
comments like oh well he was
he was laughing what happened yo
laughing sometimes
is a is a defense mechanism you ever
seen somebody so mad that they laugh
like
it's a scary scary uh yeah like
like that's different
sometimes you
you you you don't know what nothing else
to do but laugh
in in in
the most disrespectful situations a
[ __ ] just like
word
but in your in your mind and in your
heart you saying
i'ma burn this [ __ ] like that's what
you're saying like you know
it's crazy i've heard you talk about why
slapping someone
is so much more
it gets your point across so much more
than if you were to punch somebody
i'm gonna tell you to i'm gonna tell you
to really [ __ ] ever
when i was in prison
my man explained this to me and i told
the story before
he said yo because you know i wasn't i
was locked up in time and we was you
know a lot of cuttings and we was cut we
would be cutting
cutting each other and [ __ ] like that
right
and
i was getting i was trying to go home
and i was trying to get away from some
of the [ __ ] i was involved in
[Music]
so a friend of mine told me some [ __ ]
about
slapping [ __ ]
he really explained this to me like it
was a art
he said yo man you could smack [ __ ]
i said yo when you smack a [ __ ] he
gonna take that dish back he gonna go
crazy he said nah
he said
when you smack a [ __ ] why you right
when you talking to him
the average [ __ ]
is going to go into shock
you got to understand [ __ ] what all
these rappers is talking about
the average man is not
as valid as they acting like
i'm talking about
don't you ain't got time to go get your
gun and all this other [ __ ] i ain't
talking about that i'm talking about
being straight up violent
fighting cutting stabbing right here on
the spot everybody not with that all
right
so
if you smack a man the average person
the average man is going to go into like
a shot like oh my god like his mind is
going to be frazzled he just told me
because
he felt like
the audacity of you to smack him
is so shocking at the same time
it is fearful because he's saying damn
this [ __ ]
she smacked the [ __ ] out of me and
and that's what that's what chris rock
said told you same exact thing same
exactly he explained this to me many
years ago and the same thing that chris
rock displayed is what he was talking
about yes what he talked about and
it really works
i've shot it if will went on stage and
punched him totally different reaction
even if he would have took the punch
sometimes sometimes a punch is different
right
a smack is more audacious it's more
disrespectful it's a psych it's
psychological
chris said
oh [ __ ]
wow
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
and this is what he talked about i tried
it tried it many times after that and it
works
i'm telling you it really works no not
now that's not to say that
that works for every man right
you go like this to some [ __ ] and it's
and they win it
you understand so it doesn't it doesn't
work with every man but what did i say
earlier the average man is not as
violent as he thinks he is
the average walking person is just not a
violent person right i don't think
everybody's is equipped or or or
everybody isn't instinctively in violent
that way you understand so it [ __ ]
works gotta stop the interview real
quick gotta tell you about our good
folks at my bookie it's a big weekend in
college basketball we got the final four
finally going the [ __ ] down
i'm taking duke and that boy and coach k
to run that thing up all the way to the
championship baby alright i like
duke kansas
to make the championship game nice
little two-team parley right there go to
my bookie if you want to get down man
and gamble with your boy we're making
this money over here
if uh you are in one of these states and
you don't know how to get your gambling
on when it comes to sports gambling you
always see people talking about it
online listen you gotta go to
mybookie.ag
sign up for an account it's i've been
using my bookie for about eight years
and that's no cap no kids app at all
that's straight up facts i really am a
user of my bookie i [ __ ] with my bookie
the long way not only can you do the
sports gamble you could go on there and
play [ __ ] blackjack with a lady and i
don't know what country she's in but
she's she's twisting that [ __ ]
ball you know what i'm saying and
dealing them cards but go to my bookie
sign up with the promo code bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g
and when you make a deposit your first
deposit will get matched up to a
thousand dollars ncaa basketball is
about to get wrapped up then we're full
force into the nba playoffs all right
the one seed phoenix suns just put all
of your money on them you know they beat
the warriors the other night i don't
know if you saw that cook
i don't know did you see that huh
just put all your money on the suns but
listen let's get this money man i i love
sports gambling y'all know about me i'm
a i just love it i'm very passionate
about it and there's only one place i
put my bets in at it's my bookie and i'm
not saying that just because they
sponsor our podcast that's the truth so
go to mybookie.ag they make it so easy
for you to do parlays the bet
uh all kinds of player props just
whatever futures whatever you want you
can bet on [ __ ] wrestlemania bro so
what are we doing go to mybookie.ag
sign up right now use the promo code
bootleg and they will match your first
deposit free money
up to a thousand dollars let's get back
to the interview
have you ever uh
because you've been a part of some i
mean earlier on like i feel like when
you first got out and when you were
running around with kim and
obviously when you first got on atlantic
the high header days
you were a part of some public
altercations yeah um before instagram
yeah right when we would just have to
read about it on allhiphop.com or
whatever the [ __ ] right yeah
um
any of those altercations ever result in
you like
maybe 10 15 years later
burying the hatchet with any of those
because i think like uh because you had
a situation with berg right back in the
day it was
like yeah
but i'm like hit making jim jones got a
whole album coming out so like there's a
thing though and you're a different guy
you know yeah like we
every day we we we're trying to uh get
to a place where we
can be better than before right so
i can't like
sit up here and and act like
i'm i'm this
actively
involving myself with with some [ __ ]
yeah you've grown
the same guy you were back there yeah
right it's like it don't it doesn't even
make no sense so anything that i went
through before so you understand like
i a lot of the things that i have been
involved with in the way i was moving
is because i didn't know any different i
didn't know any better like you
understand where my education is coming
from only been in two places in my whole
life i've been in the street and i've
been to prison
and then you get thrown in
the fake ass
that's the only two places i've ever
been in my life
that's it
i had never been in a in a in a
corporate world i had never worked in
corporate america i had never had a a
job anything that i had done
you know
um in my life involved
the streets
and it involved you know when i went to
prison then you understand what that is
so what does that teach you these two
places that teach you how to be
violent and teach you how to survive so
it doesn't teach you how to handle your
problems um diplomatically yeah civilly
right so now when i get in the industry
and i'm saying alright cool you [ __ ]
is out here idolizing these guys over
here i'm the real thing
so
when i'm getting into things my only
action my only reaction is to deal with
it the way i
only know how to
and then people looking at me like
you bugging
right and i'm saying
yeah i don't want the real thing they're
like nah you could look like you to act
like it right we don't really want you
to do it dope right
and it took me a while to kind of really
get that
because for me it was it was
it was staining a lot of relationships
and it was kind of like
pushing opportunities away from me that
you definitely had a stigma early on but
i knew i've known you right for a long
time so i've known you since like oh
nine twenty two nine and anybody know me
now i've been always been silent super
solid i've always been always been solid
always been humble always been
you know confident but i always been
who i was you know and always been solid
right but you've always had your
principles you've always had right you
know look right i think people know you
don't [ __ ] around with maynard like and
that's that's not a bad thing but you
know right i definitely think that you
definitely had a stigma right but if you
ain't but if you don't
if you don't hit the top
automatically
and you got to fight for everything that
you got to get
then you then when you when you got that
stigma and chases the money away
you understand so if you if you're a
[ __ ] that
hit straight to the top
and they got to deal with you see they
have to deal with me right
but as soon as i have a record
then it was like okay [ __ ]
we don't have to deal with him right
he's not that big
he's not that hot
so
that's the difference so then you you
actually running the the the money away
because when you're not hot
and you're not on fire and you're not
the the rapper at the time
then your relationships in in in your in
who you are
help you through that time right you
understand
like just being who you are and just
having certain relationships can still
keep you afloat into you until you find
your next situation whether that's a uh
another record or another deal whatever
100 do you understand oh we see it all
the time yeah no that's fair i think um
like you said like i think if somebody
is
scorching right people are willing to
look past a lot of people do whatever
i mean nba young boy
like if y'all if young boy wasn't doing
the numbers he was people be like this
guy's crazy like what what are we doing
with this guy like he's stirring [ __ ] up
with the world like when you're on fire
you can do whatever you want to do
when you gotta when you got a claw and
you gotta climb and you gotta scramble
for everything that you got
or everything that you trying to get
and they making you work for it because
that ain't that they never made it easy
for me i had to work for everything no i
know man you understand so people oh you
doing your thing like
[ __ ] like [ __ ]
it's crazy too because like your first
album to me is still one of the more
slept on albums in the last like 15
years i know you did the sequel
um but that first project the way you
like put together your story from the
first record i see i see people get
credit for
having that style the concept of this
project making it like a movie and all
that and i say like i did that
and you did it flawlessly and nobody
really talks about it
but the people who experienced it with
me such a good album right but they
practiced
great album in the way we did it it was
like a movie it told my life story from
beginning i still bump souls all the
time right right
and because i was a fan of actually
when people really made
um um albums that was concepts
in the 90s there was a lot of conceptual
albums like yeah
we put together
albums that felt like movies so i was a
fan of that and i wanted to tell my
story it was very important to me right
so
i don't get the credit and i watch
people give the same credit
to other people for doing that but you
know what i don't get stuck there though
boy
i don't get stuck in
the fact that
i'm i'm underrated
right you understand i don't get stuck
there because when you when you when
you're stuck on what the problem is you
you're not looking for the solution so
[ __ ] the fact that
that people that people don't get it
let's just keep working
let's just keep let's just keep pushing
let's keep opening doors let's keep
doing things
and slowly and short slowly but surely
people will see what it is and that's
what's happening now we have the podcast
we got the you know the
music coming so it's a lot of [ __ ]
happening now that wasn't happening for
me two years ago was my bandana on that
album or it was on a tape right that was
on a mixtape mixer yeah is that is that
on spotify
it might be i feel like it's not like
that i feel like every time i hear it i
gotta go on that piff it might be yeah
because remember it was that wasn't
around that record was crazy
lloyd banks was on that right yeah yeah
um talk about the lobby boy [ __ ] because
obviously you and jim come together
doing a
uh a collab he's he's on fire right he's
in his bag right i feel like he's
rapping at the highest level he's ever
wrapped that and that's the thing and
then and
he helped me
right because you got to think
musically he had more he had he had
had a lot more going on than i did
he's been much more active right he's
been way more active and it wasn't that
i wasn't working it was the fact that i
felt like i was i kept being in
situations that that was not
allowing me to to touch the people
meaning i was dropping projects
you know
and it and because i didn't have the the
the
the push or the right structure or the
right situation it wasn't getting there
people would say like when you gonna
drop something like i just dropped
something three months i just dropped
something two three months ago like you
ain't oh i ain't even know
and that's like that really bothers you
when you put your work
you you put your heart
and then you you dealing with a a label
whether that's independent or you
dealing with distribution
and they put it out
and yet
nobody
knows so
me and jim always talked about doing the
lobby boys projects project back when
when when puff
and and and ross would say that they was
the bugatti boys so me and him had a
record back then and we said uh he said
on the record he said uh
um shout out to the bugatti boys but me
and maine are we the lobby boys
and we always this is years ago we got
to do album together we always talked
about that but you know sometimes the
hardest thing in the world is to get two
artists to be on the same page at the
same time of course so
you know years go by and you know our
relationship is just just got strong and
strong through the years but
you know i hit him one day i was just in
that mode after after the pandemic and i
said yo i'm almost ready bro mentally i
just needed to get there once i got my
podcast rolling i wanted to get that
you know solid i wanted to have other
things going on other than just music
i wanted to have other components and
you know what i mean so i got that
rolling and then
i called them and said yo listen i'm
ready
let me go in the studio first though
and get some [ __ ] off my chest
and
and i did like four five six records and
he came down he was just like oh
let's go and we and we just started
banging [ __ ] out every day and um and
the project is is we found the formula
man like we got it like this is
i mean this is uh
this is going to be very serious i
guarantee you this is uh
you're going to love it man i would love
to hear you like lock in
with like kind of like what jim did with
the heat makers from for capo with like
a produce like one producer
and just give me like who the producer i
mean we gotta find them as an alchemist
because uh
scram jones would be hard like
me and um
me and uh he me and uh what's the name
from the heat makers just talked about
doing that um
i don't want to hear no club [ __ ] from
you i don't hear no radio [ __ ] from you
i want you to talk that [ __ ] talk but
you know the thing is this though um
so with the lobby boys it's not really
nice some club [ __ ] like but you
understand that's that's that's who i am
this is true and you're actually at the
club yeah like
i make music for who of who i am yeah
right so it's like
i i want to be able to go out and hear
be like yo tell the dj here's my
i was the outside [ __ ] so a lot of
[ __ ] that make a lot of the
underground [ __ ] like that they [ __ ]
that just
the lifestyle is different right i'm the
i like the women and i like the parties
i like the outside you know i probably
don't go out as much as i used to
but that's my lifestyle i like that you
understand and you know i'll you would
see me places you know new york la all
over and and you'll see me outside
usually with an ig thought or two or
seven with women yeah i like women man
and
you know i like to have a good time so
sometimes the music is going to reflect
that which is fine yeah
um
as far as like just catalog wise like
you have a bunch of catalog but like
with the like when there's guys like jim
or the griselda guys dropping so often
is that something you're interested in
doing but like you know what maybe next
year i got to put out four projects so
so so what happened is that
now that i see
the game has changed and now that this
lobby boy [ __ ] is gonna really help me
right it's gonna help me
a lot
so i'm already
three projects in
so i already have
my two
next project's ready so you all ready so
we already saw my videos and everything
clips ready
ready wow so the clip so once the lobby
boys hit
it's like you heard the first record
right yeah lobby boys anthem all right
cool so
you know we we we about to uh drop
another one we gotta drink with fab uh
favio we we we it's coming
once that happens and once we get
through that cycle i got another one
waiting and then i got another one
waiting
i think that's the way to go that's the
only way to go
and i like it now because we can still
it's fun now because we can still do we
can still do all that music
and still go over here and do my podcast
and do other things so that's what i
like about today
is the fact that you can have so many
different components to who you are so
what your brand is that you can still do
it we just did the deal with fox souls
too i saw that yes for a kitchen talk
exactly and it's not about me being a
rapper right so this is this is the
things that i like well it's funny
because like
once i mean obviously joe has always
done like some sort of version of like
podcasting or vlogging or whatever but
you know i always thought
guys like yourself guys like fat joke
guys like nori before norrie did drink
jing champs i was like man like i would
like to hear these guys interview people
yeah these guys talk yeah like you're
like
was always one of those guys on that
list so when you started your [ __ ] i was
like finally yeah you know what i mean
like it took me a minute people were
saying that to me it was like yo you you
need to do a podcast and i was like
alright cool i'm gonna do what i'm doing
and i was always and then look
years ago well it was me and uncle
murder we had did a a a a a deal with
revolt where we had a a show it was
called uh
brooklyn boys i think we shot two
episodes but it never came out and it
was nothing to do with with us it was
whatever revolt was going through at the
time so
i was just trying to fight i was taking
meetings people was coming at me about
doing podcasting and i was trying to
figure out
what i what i wanted what i wanted
wanted it to be about and how i wanted
to present it
and you know what it is it's like you
just want up procrastinating big time
when you're looking for this look you're
also looking for excuse as to why you're
not you haven't started it right because
you're like oh i can't do it like that
you got to be like this
and you keep over overthinking and
overthinking and over analyzing that you
never do [ __ ] so
i'm sitting
on quarantine
i'm at home
i'm saying [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i just went and
bought me some studio equipment for my
house learned how to engineer a little
bit started recording myself
then i say you know what
we're gonna shoot the podcast
in the kitchen
we're going because we always hanging
out in the kitchen
in the street first place you go
is the kitchen it's the beginning it's
the beginning of [ __ ] right the kitchen
is where you go
and
i'm like
[ __ ] i don't know how i'm gonna do it
we're gonna paint this wall
we're just gonna do it and and that's
what it was we just did it and i made
all those mistakes and kept going and
kept going and kept going kept going
the greatest thing you could do is just
keep going
that's what i tell everybody the problem
is is i mean dude
obviously i've been doing terrestrial
radio forever so like i planned on doing
like
the bootleg head podcast while i was
also doing radio
but i'd always been like man i was
supposed to do something with nori
mm-hmm um because nori had was working
on his drink champs network so when i
had announced i was going to do my
podcast nori had hit me like don't do it
yet i'm assigned you to my [ __ ]
ended up not working out whatever
so then i was like all right well if i'm
gonna launch this
i really need to make sure the first
guest is [ __ ] crazy like i gotta make
sure
and i just would i just psyched myself
out for like two years
then the pandemic happened
i'm still a real i'm still at real to
this day but right we can't go into the
radio station we can't do in-person
interviews
the ig live interviews were [ __ ]
trash
so i'm like i just bought a recording
studio right right these [ __ ]
can't tell me what i do at my place
right
and
i was like let me just get you know
freddie gibbs is one of my best friends
i was like let me just get fred to come
on and shoot the [ __ ] with me and we're
just going to drop it and the [ __ ] went
crazy and 160 episodes in
in two a year year and a half
dope yeah we got to stop the interview
right now uh listen man
i got to say about bluetooth our good
folks at blue chew one of our sponsors
for the podcast and a product that i use
all right now everyone thinks that you
know maybe
taking a product like blue chew which
has the same active ingredients as
cialis and viagra is a thing it's not a
thing it's very normal you might have
anxiety you might have stress you need
that confidence to get your [ __ ] on
alright trust me
you want to lay thor's hammer down on
that puss you know what i'm saying or
that butthole whatever you're into
let me tell you something the best part
about blue chew not only is it in a
chewable form but you know when we think
about going to the doctor's office and
getting um a prescription for something
like this we think about it as a maybe
an embarrassing conversation to have an
awkward conversation to have well
bluechu is an online prescription
service there's no visits to the
doctor's office that's right it ships
right to your door in a discreet package
and when i tell you blue chew helps you
if you're a man
achieve a harder and stronger erection
believe me when i say bud it's the
[ __ ] truth all right
it helps men combat all forms of ed all
right and let me tell you if you're
getting ready to go on a date
you just want to impress a young lady
you got to pop that blue chew man that'd
have your dick
you it might add a half an inch to your
dick your dick's never bits hard in your
[ __ ] life
i mean serious ain't being serious yo
even if you just want to jerk off and
just be like yo this is nice it's
[ __ ] amazing so go over to blue chew
it is a chewable tablet you don't got to
swallow it no pills nothing like that
bluetooth licensed medical providers
they work with you they find the right
ingredient and the right strength for
your prescription it's so easy you go to
bluetooth.com consult with their
licensed medical providers and use the
promo code bootleg put it on the screen
bootleg at checkout all you gotta do is
pay five dollar shipping and they're
gonna give you your first month of
bluetooth for free that's right you can
try baluchu for free go to bluechu.com
use the promo code bootleg and receive
your first month free
man oh man
i am a user of the blue chew and i [ __ ]
with a shot shout out to blue chew let's
get back to the interview but like you
said man if you really is very much
procrastination is like the biggest
right and that's probably
anything anything like starting a
business though anything working out
starting being an artist and being an
artist anything anything that that
that's
creative anything that takes effort um
most people don't it's easy to just get
up and do it do what you're told it's
easy super easy but and just follow
instructions because you don't have to
think for that there's no there's no
there's not much effort there's a
program i got to be up by seven i got to
be out of the house by eight when i get
to work i move these boxes here or i
stock this shelf right so it doesn't
take it doesn't take much and and that
is most of the world like most of the
population
you know is is is our followers
and that's the thing
um it takes much more courage to get up
and do something
that is more challenging or to do
something that unknown outside of your
comfort zone yeah that's the key feel me
it's it's scary
you had the light for you it was like
trial and error i'm sure with the
pockets everything everything my whole
career my whole life when i came home
from prison i said i'm gonna do this
music [ __ ] i didn't i didn't know
nothing i didn't know i didn't really
have music friends i didn't i didn't i
didn't have real uh uh studio experience
i'm not coming from a music background
i'm in in in and when i came in there
was no other rappers that had done what
i had done it was no other artist that
was ever that ever did the amount of
time that i had done that beca that was
successful none
i'm one of one hundred percent yeah at
that time yeah no other artists had
had
there was no other artist
that was in the music business
that had done
a a large amount of prison time
that became successful artists after
prison after prison that's real
yeah people had small bids a year or two
here you know but yeah no that's real
nah no nobody
what is your uh you know cause new york
in general right now um we on fire on
fire we're on fire shout out to the you
know the homie nems who we've had coming
up on the show since 2017.
he was just with me up on uh
always been an incredible artist yeah he
got [ __ ] bars yeah i like that guy
his personality yeah i like that guy
and he's somebody who stayed down too
because he's been doing this [ __ ] for a
minute stay down long enough to come up
100 you know what i mean and like i said
about this era we living in social media
you don't know how you're gonna get it
he got hot off of
just being for him being himself being
funny on social media yeah which led
people back to his music so and the
music checked out right good music yes
and it's good music yeah that's real i
mean obviously the buffalo boys are
killing and shout out to zelda
definitely we got gazelle on the album
oh that's gonna be big we got gizelle
like who all from griselda like everyone
conway benny conway on one joint and we
got uh benny on another joint oh that's
big yeah that's big man and then he
joined crazy benny's on fire right yeah
i love benny how are you uh
like i feel like what what they've done
is very much kind of like
it's kind of like a renaissance of like
the [ __ ] we kind of grew up loving
in terms of like you know sound just
sonically and just i just appreciate
just straight and i just appreciate like
they don't like i've i'm like you know
benny's got records that like
have like big artists on him but like i
don't like i've never heard them
force
a radio record or like you know what i'm
saying like it's like they're like yo
this is what we do
but like i said it all it all goes back
to your lifestyle yeah it all goes goes
back to the type of person you are you
know what i'm saying you
you know
you use playing with pistols and getting
money in the street then that's probably
what you want to talk about you know
and if you know
eating [ __ ] and and having three sims
with you
was you what you was doing on leisure
that's going to come out too in the
music you know what i mean shout out to
you
what's the most amount of uh women at
once
that mayno's had at one time um
not that six maybe six yeah so a
sevensome technically are you that's the
seventh song are you the seventh or the
fifth yeah that's a seven that's that's
no maybe five between five and i want to
say five or six
so a six or seven tim definitely five
though i can't remember
can't figure out if it was made so when
you're [ __ ] five chicks yeah it's a
lot of work obviously the girls got to
be handling each other as well
there's only so much it's not fun all
the way i was gonna say like
it almost feels like more work than it
is is it was it worth is it fun i guess
is my question
or is it kind of like yes a lot of that
[ __ ] is like eat your ego
your appetite your mind you ever look at
food and be like yo
i want that and your eyes is doing more
than what your stomach can hold every
day so it's kind of like
you know
that the thought and idea of having all
these women
at one time sounds amazing it sounds
crazy it's just it's just wow you know
and so i mean
it works
you made it work it works it happens but
all that's just
you know
um that's your leisure
do you make sure the girls know each
other first like are they all homies is
that healthy this doesn't happen all the
time i don't i don't want to show you
the one time it did happen
give me the scenario oh how you
convinced six chicks to [ __ ] you at the
same time yeah they they uh
damn i'm trying to think it was if it
was five or six you got like one chick
who like wrangles them all up let's just
say it was five okay five
oh good number i was i was out
i had a girl that
used to
like to have girls around all the time
she had some girls and it was just one
girl that we didn't know
and um
i want to say
yeah it was one girl that we didn't know
and then we brought her around and you
know yeah i mean girl see the thing
about women is that they click easier
than men
this is true you know especially girls
who are kind of like right they friendly
right at each other they they they
really uh
by curious right so they they click
quicker than [ __ ] do like you all you
need is alcohol
some hookah
some hookah yeah nick cooking
some booze and some hoodie
in local that's it
from there it's off to the races they're
clicking hey how are you man
over there yeah i know
oh you know what's the name oh what's
your page
they they following each other and then
turn around and kissing
wow this is this is yeah
it's amazing this is life
you know
i'm just trying to think how like
physically like that would work that's
like an orgy low-key that sounds like
pretty much what it is some real pharaoh
[ __ ] though so my king [ __ ] it doesn't
happen every day that's not regular once
a lifetime i mean like two is what's a
lifetime solid two is regular two's
regular for you it's regular for anybody
how many
i don't know about for anybody two is
regular for any that's really regular
girls give me the over under on how many
threesomes you think you've had in your
entire life that's what's that number
this is
north of 50
under 50
definitely more than 50. you've had more
than 50 threesomes of course that's not
that's that's pretty regular like that's
pretty standard
standard it's a standard standard mano
[ __ ] that's not it's not about me it's
about you no it's not about me that's
not standard
you serious
yeah
you're bugging no you're bugging no
you're bugging that's standard 50.
i've had a handful of those situations
what's a handful less than 10.
okay more than five less than ten
somewhere in that range now you're north
of fifty standard brother like that's i
mean we're talking about
we're talking i'm we talking about
uh
so if you've had more than 50
threesomes
on the low end that's 100 chicks
are we knocking on are you mayno
chamberlain damn i can't what you know
north of a thousand chicks in your life
let me
no i'm not gonna say that would you say
more or less than a thousand i'm not
gonna say anything listen what i'ma say
is this i mean you already put a number
on the threesomes no
is 50 a lot of three times it's just
that it happened 50 times this is what
you're saying
yeah 50 different threesomes
but this that's the amount of time
that's me some girls might be the same
some cast members in these threesomes
might have stayed consistent right okay
right okay that's what i'm saying right
exactly
so here's the thing
that's in like 15 how long i've been
home
what year did you come home 2003.
so that's 19 years ago
that's crazy okay so this is an
expanse of 19 years so is that that many
is that it's not that much i mean i'm 35
and it's not that much
listen i respect it it's not it's not a
it's not a big thing when you cause
because like i feel like we do kind of
know mayno to always have a bad chick
around right
is it kind of funny to be like
when you're dealing with that many women
and you are mano you have to be eskimo
brothers with a lot of other rappers
what does that mean that means you guys
both [ __ ] the same chick
but certainly for certain right
like has that ever happened where you
may be like
we're [ __ ] around with because i know
i have another good friend of mine
who's kind of similar to you in terms of
just always with a and he'll he's like
had like beefs with nba players like
other rappers like is that something
that's happened with you yeah especially
see the rappers is a little more cool
about it
it's the ballplayers they really get in
their feelings all the time married ass
ball players all the time like listen
no i don't not even just married
anything like with a ball player
yeah they get they get a little bit
crazy about it like it it's
i heard james harden's like that
i don't know i never uh you never smash
one of his chicks
not that i know of no no maybe yeah so
you had a pro did you have a problem
with a specific player ever like where
it was like
um
no but
i think a specific player had a problem
with me
right
yeah what team just tell us
he's a funny guy
give me the team of the year and give me
one guess
i can't give you the team man like but
i'll tell you what i'll tell you what
though like
i think that they was feeling some kind
of way about me though
the girl was telling me she was like oh
yo this [ __ ] said that you know you
don't speak to him when you see him i'm
like i don't even see that [ __ ] matter
of fact i don't know what that [ __ ]
look like
yeah i just know the name because yeah
he's
tall
it's so funny because that is such a
real thing there's like i got homies in
the nba and they got real issues with
other players
oh and it's always over girls that
everyone [ __ ] yeah it's always over and
this and a lot of times
i got a homie who has problems with
another player and that player is
married with kids and it's mad that his
side chick is i'm like you got
bro like what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah that's that's that's
interesting
they don't yeah i don't know this is
different
i never had a problem with an artist
though
[Music]
i never i never had a problem with
rapper
that's that's i think most of the time
artists kind of know what it is right
it's like look bro yeah bro like you
know
i'm trying to yeah i mean
it's funny that when you when you when
you when you uh
when you might be dealing with a chicken
and you you run across a text and you
see or
and you see who be texting
like oh wow this is interesting wow
damn you got a lot of blue checks in
your dms there so yeah this [ __ ] be
begging wow crazy i know i probably got
caught like that plenty of times so i
know somebody rolled over and said oh
you got manual in your world let me see
man look at this [ __ ] nasty like
[Laughter]
this
does not give a [ __ ] and i love it man
i love it um
you know another trend that happened
during the pandemic was a lot of artists
tyga launched and only fans the only
fans uh what's the ruby rose launch the
only fan tiger was [ __ ] on his [ __ ]
though
yeah uh was that something that ever
came across your mind i don't got that
hard
i don't got the heart to do that
he don't give a [ __ ] obviously when you
don't listen he publicly dated a 17 year
old or she was 16 when they were dating
yeah that's a difference he definitely
don't give a [ __ ]
yeah he see people like that though a
part of me admired him
because i was like you you so free in
your mind
yeah that's a different type of freedom
you got to be free you got a real zero
shame right that's a
that's admirable now i'm not saying go
[ __ ] date a 17 year old but i'm just
saying the fact that you could be up
there [ __ ] on video on video and then
you have and you have a single on the
radio right now and yeah it's it's crazy
like you cannot yeah that's different
and he always be getting repo'd and [ __ ]
like that and he just never ever seemed
like he gave give a [ __ ]
that's a no what i'm saying like
no that's right i'm just saying right
i think i think that's
right this happened whatever i mean
whatever he was going through what i
liked about
people like him is that it just never
seemed phased
i like that that's admirable
do you feel like because i do feel like
there was a
in hip hop a dark age of 2017 2018 is
when i think [ __ ] got goofy for a while
soundcloud right uh the x uh uh the uh
takashi [ __ ] like i just feel like it
was a real goofy era of shitty rap that
was popping where it was more about
antics more about instagram [ __ ]
than it was about the actual music
um i feel like we've kind of gotten
through that yeah yeah it's back to
wrapping everybody's back it feels good
i thought the pandemic helped a bit it's
rapping um
but what how difficult was it for you to
kind of be who you are
and like
you know at the time you know you think
of like who was like screaming they were
the king of new york it was this guy
with rainbow hair and not even to even
get into his specific situation but like
just being mano and like watching where
the music industry went and how it kind
of went so far away from authenticity
and kind of what you bring to the table
was like what was it like to do with
that but this is this is why i'm still
here it's because i was able to still be
myself no matter what
you understand um
i was still able to withstand some of
some of the things that was going on
because you got to understand and know
that some of the [ __ ] that be happening
is just it's just
it's a date on it it's it's just a fad
it's just inspiration date on so much of
this [ __ ] right so when i i i kind of
always know that like this [ __ ] is not
forever you know what i mean this some
of this [ __ ] is going it's gonna gonna
gonna blow by and we we gonna be like oh
remember what's let's go and get to that
so
the only thing i could say for me
and to keep me away from being
frustrated or angry with the industry
because nothing is not going the way i
would want them to go it's just
you know
like you're in a boxing ring stay
focused on what's in front of you
you understand stay focused on your
opponent i don't be looking at other
[ __ ] i don't really be i'm not in the
competition with with nobody the only
person i'm in competition with is the
person in the mirror you understand so
he's the person that i got to deal with
because at the end of the day who am i
battling i got to battle my own demons
in the dark at night i gotta battle it's
me versus me
you understand like it ain't nothing
else
i'm my only opponent i just told that to
my boy i was telling him like uh
because you know i have a friend who
always is bringing up
what other people in his similar space
are doing can't do that that'll that'll
[ __ ] you around it'll [ __ ] you up and i
think
when i was super young
i would really like feel like i should
have i should be doing like i'm better
than what this guy's doing in my you
know radio [ __ ] but like you know like
once you start once you get rid of that
mentality got it right throw that away
yo it literally will change your life
right if you just worry about what is it
like you said well you can control right
i control what i can control and
everything else what what's going on
over here with this person they got [ __ ]
to do with me good for them i'm happy
for them i walk in the club and
the new hot [ __ ] is dead oh my god man
i'm like alright cool [ __ ] it i'm right
here too though you know and that pocket
watching [ __ ] i have you [ __ ] up man
yeah you worried about what what other
[ __ ] are doing how much [ __ ] is
making when [ __ ] came out because i
would i had this
we all
fall victim to some of these things
sometimes right but it's not it's about
staying there right because i i had like
damn this [ __ ] came after me
he used to just
man this [ __ ] used to want to be next
to me now he
up here you understand how the [ __ ] this
thing get past me
i had to get out of that because the
more i thought about that the more
frustrated i became and when i became
frustrated i became insecure
so when you're insecure you can't you
can't move you can't you can't produce
you don't know what to do you don't know
how to make music you don't know how to
talk you don't know how to speak you
don't know how you're not confident
once you lose your confidence you lose
everything like it's not even like
you're just a [ __ ] up [ __ ] so so
you can't
be caught up in
the [ __ ] that you can't control i'm in
my car
right
and if i'm in my car i'm in my lane
right
i can't be driving my car and looking in
the lane
next to me because what i'm gonna crash
that's some real [ __ ]
i think it's some almost like some grown
man [ __ ] though to get there you gotta
[ __ ] [ __ ] stay my eyes is on the road
like [ __ ] man like sometimes i think
damn i wish i had my where my head is
right now 10 years ago yeah but you know
what we developed the way we listen but
here's the thing if sometimes
you know you got to go through that to
get to where you're at today so it's
like yeah that's really it's it's okay
it's just like it's the journey and it's
there's no better time than the present
time so
you know
your car's moving though right 100
it may not be going as fast as
this one or that one but it's moving and
in life we always in the same place
right we're always in the same place
this is the place that we in in life
we always in the middle and what i mean
by that is this there's always people
that's doing
better than you
and always people that you're doing
better than all six always it's like
you're always a man no matter what no
matter what yeah you got 100 million
somebody with
with 200 million you understand yeah you
got 300 million and somebody with a
billion so i mean what's up yo we got to
stop the interview real quick shout out
to our presenting sponsor odd socks baby
hey man listen all i keep on my ass is
odd socks draws all i keep in my feet
socks you know why because they're the
most comfortable socks in the world and
i'm not just saying this because they
promote the podcast i'm telling you the
socks are crazy they got all the
licenses look they got halloween socks
they have back to the future socks
they got [ __ ] twizzler socks old
dirty bastard socks r.i.p to odb all
right they also got their draws if you
want to wear some underwear with pizza
on them whatever you need but my
favorite are the odd socks basics baby
these are just the plain boys these to
me are the most comfortable socks in the
world all right
so trust me when i say go to
oddssoxofficial.com
thank me later when you go to check out
find the most comfortable socks in the
world
get some wwe socks too i just saw a
sneak peek of the new wwe line and
they're [ __ ] insane
in [ __ ] sane uh go to
oddssocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev that's one word together
bootleg kev
we should talk to them about shortening
that bootleg cab is the promo code you
will get 20 off at checkout one more
time go to oddssocksofficial.com save 20
off using that promo code bootleg kev
let's get back to the interview for you
um kind of being like a personality i
mean you've always been a personality um
i've always loved when you would go on
your rants on the car on instagram right
i mean
um but just in terms of like
really being you know you you have a
podcast that's successful now right
how different does that have you
approaching
the entertainment industry because
you're kind of on the other side of it
as well as still doing the artist [ __ ]
but i feel like now like
there might be people who have never
heard your music who might come up to
you now and be like i love
what i love your this episode of your
podcast
it's a different thing right that's the
great thing about the time we in
is that you don't it's not just about
the music
it's about a brand
so now that
you know i don't have to just focus
solely on music i can focus on all the
other things that i got going on right
so we talked about fit lit we talked
about lobby boys we talked about you
know
kitchen talk these are different
components
you know it's so many things that we can
do at the same time you know it's
different components right so the fact
that i could you know i could i could
come out here you know i could just you
know jump on this show with with macy
yesterday and perform live in front of
nbc and and turn around and promote my
podcast the next day you did the record
with macy yesterday well we performed it
yesterday
on that show that she got well we
performed the live on nbc biggest look
i've ever had yeah i saw i saw you doing
something with nbc never never did
nothing like that you know on um on on
that on that type of stage so that was a
big look for me you know um the fact
that i could do that and still turn
around and
push the podcast
go to the gym do that
do all the other [ __ ] i got going on
this is the greatest time man it's the
best what are we talking about i mean
look we think of someone like um
your biggest record is all is it is all
the above right yeah t-pain yeah what is
pain doing everything he wants to do
this is what i'm saying it's
[ __ ] hosting television shows
his twitch is popping his podcast and
he's still dropping crazy music it's
about a brand you don't have to ever
leave the music it's not sports i just
like the fact that the stigma of like
artists doing other [ __ ] right because
you know we used to think like well if
you have a podcast you're washed or if
you're doing reality tv
but i feel like nowadays
it's it's
this is what we're doing right i think
people kind of got out of that that's a
good 100 i think that that thought about
oh well this [ __ ] washed up that's why
he's doing that oh music um you still
got ignorant ignorant people
but the general public those people are
trying to recoup still right
record deals that they signed anyway the
general the general public i think that
they kind of
understand that so to speak because we
we've watched so many artists do so many
different things you know we watch
how mary is on a hit yeah
television show and then and she's gonna
do super music and then put an album out
right instead of doing uh she did the
super bowl so you can do
different various different things and
and here's the thing the the whole uh uh
the whole conversation about who's
relevant and what's relevant is being
changed every day mm-hmm you understand
like you know uh
when you got artists like jim jones
still was able to
to push out a hit
right now
you understand um
[Music]
music is relative man you know what i
mean so it's like you say well what's
who
this guy's not relevant well he's
relevant to the people that love him
yeah it's his fan base
there you go yeah now that might be it
might not be the little baby fan base
but that's cool right that's okay
that's okay [ __ ] 100 percent we
everything
well you know what too is different now
is
your
independence is now i feel like
more artists understand how important it
is
that's where maybe like 10 or 15 years
ago
you cool off you're still tied to this
shitty major label and they're not gonna
let you drop whenever you want as
opposed to now if you're if your gym and
you you you yeah jim has been to me
relevant for i never stopped being
relevant right and i feel like he's put
out some of the best projects of the
last i mean last few years i mean we
could you know uh
and i feel like
if maybe jim was on like
[ __ ] def jam or something or atlantic
or something like it might have been
like you know he's in a situation where
right i want to go do a full project
with harry fraud right
and the people who are going to
appreciate it are going to appreciate
right right and that's and that's what i
had to get
into my mind understanding that
appeal to the people that love you yeah
now through social media
that's going to help you gain new fans
every day for it may not be from the
music maybe from the way i talk or the
podcast so it's it's a great time and
you're just pulling from all these from
all different areas man and then you got
you know jim just put out we set the
trans which is already that's what i'm
talking about how the [ __ ] this late in
the game right right still still putting
out hits bad joe
fat joe
and trust me
i'm about to we about to hurt something
everybody
like like like i was telling you man i
just would love to see you run up that
just run it up man
when you say you got three projects
ready to go that's good to hear no we're
gonna run it up i had to really
understand that but i had to really
regroup sometimes you gotta
sometimes you gotta reset man you gotta
reset in order to
to really compete the way you want to
observe
observe
right and then you gotta get busy so now
i'm now a minute i'm in a
i'm in a different space and people can
see the difference you're in the get
busy space yeah yeah 100 man
um who for you like
who are the younger artists that you
actually listen to and appreciate man
all of them
like who's like if i checked your
spotify who's the most
who you bumping the most that's that's
not you know of your era or later
i mean
[ __ ] man what's my error right what
would you consider my error is people
who've come out how about
in the last five years i've been bumping
dirt all week dirk okay right but dirk
been around for he has been around here
you know what i'm saying people forget
dirk been around a minute that's what
i'm saying i've been bumping dirt um i
love baby um nobody's amazing uh all the
young [ __ ] from new york
definitely all the young [ __ ] from new
york
fabio's on fire yeah five years is my
god like this is
that's really uh
my god i think it it's it's crazy but
it's also dope that like it really took
that kanye versus people to realize how
dope of a rapper he was
because i i feel like people who knew
knew
like telling people a long time that he
really could rap right and and i don't
and and i tell him that like
he don't know he don't sound like nobody
else no he's crazy he has his own style
and and it's really dope um
and people really don't see the record
that we have with him is a smash
yeah there's a smash this is what i'm
saying listen to what i'm telling you on
your album on the lobby boys project
it's a smash
smash listen to what i'm saying video
done
record is done
he's coming how are you guys dropping
the uh lobby boys project so we did a
deal with uh one rpm shot one rpm they
distribute a couple of my boys yeah so
we did a deal with them um
and we got a lot of dope features on
there man like i told you we got a fabio
in there fab on there uh
uh april she's coming soon and yeah and
then ending them on april 29th is the
date we got
yeah
why did you never um
go anywhere like
like like really like dive into acting
because i feel like you could kill it
i mean what people ask me that i do
do roles when i when i catch it right so
whenever i catch a road
i come i'll come to la i feel like you
never really dived in i didn't because
when i started to see that
it to me was a
more of a struggle than
the music
i mean a lot a lot of these young audits
a lot of these young actors are not
really getting paid well you got to leg
up on them though because you're mayno
don't mean nothing in it in that world
so that's the thing people think that it
does it does feel like there's got to be
a recurring role in power for it gets
you it gets you in the door but it's not
a lot it's not when i saw that
i came out to la and i had some active
friends and i seen that they it it
really wasn't what i thought it was
it made me feel like i didn't want to
pursue it as hard so what i i want to
always be involved with
with producing things
so
if i'm going to act in it
you know hopefully i'm involved with it
with the creative because that's where
the meat and potatoes is at so i got
things that i created myself that i'm
trying to find homes for then i'm trying
to find um places to to put out so the
thing about just
chasing because that's a whole different
grind you know you might go on [ __ ] a
hundred
you know crowds
and land one thing this is what i'm
saying yeah and and it takes a lot of
time so when you shoot in one movie
that's that takes i was out here last
april
shooting the movie
and
for like two weeks long every day
i like it but i got a lot of respect for
the ones that that's what they do right
and
it's just not my grind right because the
actor tell me told me um active friend
of mine told me
as soon as they yell cut on that movie
i'm unemployed
yeah
and then i gotta get the next thing
you understand so because yeah because
like not most actors 99.9 of actors who
are in [ __ ] don't get residual income
off of
that's what i'm saying
like there's not a star neither true so
you might seen such such in this movie
such a sessions movie where you're not
really doing that well in life
you understand so
you know um
you just hired
you just hired help you prefer to be
behind the scenes [ __ ] right you know
what's crazy is i do think that what's
missing from tv right now
when i was growing up we had oz
then there was the show prison break
there's not a good [ __ ] prison
[ __ ] show right now this guy wants to
watch prison no ass did you watch
ourselves oh of course i did us was
[ __ ] crazy i just had leon on my show
he was in us and prison break was super
i mean
i never watched two seasons am i missing
the show i never watched prison
oh i've heard about mayor kingstown with
jeremy renner
i've heard about that where's that at
paramount plus
that's that's a prison joint i heard
it's gonna the mayor of kingstown
it's got um hawkeye from the march i
know i know i
this book i know who that is
shout out to jeremy renner yeah that's
it's fire
same guys who do yellowstone yes exactly
i didn't watch y'all
yellowstone is good too fire i wanna
watch it some gangster cowboy [ __ ] man
yeah
yo yellowstone is like the wire but like
in in montana on a ranch really it's a
thugged out [ __ ] bro
yeah i know jeremy i remember when he
was in uh the town the town was slain
slain was in the town
yeah shout out to slain man
slain slaying the white boy the chubby
white dude who also was rapping he was
putting [ __ ] out of static selector
he's like the goon in the movie yeah i
remember the fact i don't know he was
right he's he was a rapper first wow
slain yeah from boston shout out to boss
the town was fire yeah that's fine that
might be ben affleck's best movie
is it his best movie or the other one
was the other one with him and matt
damon that won all the awards with robin
williams
the first one to pop them off
you've never seen it i don't even know
what the [ __ ] it's called
all i know is he just bought a 80
million dollar house with jlo so ben
affleck is winning you know what i'm
saying well listen bro uh lobby boys in
april lobby boys in april kitchen talk
everything's happening man how often do
you put out uh episodes of kitchen talk
every week so once a week yeah once a
week sometimes we might miss a week you
know what's gonna say like
sometimes
is it like yo this week is lit and and
what i like about your podcast is it's
not necessarily a guest-based show right
sometimes you know but we we we have
more guests now because people just like
to to see other people all
but sometimes we do two episodes
a day
like so sometimes i might have two
different guests on one day
and then you'll spread those out yes but
i'm all you know sometimes i might
i've done three episodes in one week to
have them mm-hmm come out like that so i
just have them like that but the
consistency is what's is what is what is
you know what people it's important yeah
it's very important so
you know
i got an episode coming out thursday
who helps you with
because what's important is like
getting those social media clips from
the podcast together you got you got
that team that just handles all that i
got a whole team the whole squad i got a
whole producer video
the whole team
i got people to help me uh with the
guests i got you know uh people that
shoot i got editor i got a sound person
i got the whole
team graphics everything well listen
go support yeah i know you got other
[ __ ] coming yeah that you probably can't
talk about yet you talked a little bit
about it off camera a little tv show
situation coming maybe with the homies
yeah we'll see yeah we'll see you know
shout out to fit lit
boys you already know man there it is
man may know yeah boom